so people watched the final message and
they saw a different andrew tate i don't
know what went on in between the final
message
and this rumble video will ask you that
maybe maybe you can actually first
provide some insight into that because
the question that everyone left the
final message was what is he going to do
next he implies through that video that
he's going to take some time
he at one point says that he's only
going to do stuff that's positive
it was a little bit confusing to me i
said is his whole tone going to change
now is he not going to hold people
accountable i was confused as to where
he was headed
then that closes i don't know if then he
gets a deal with rumble something
happens something happens there he comes
out in this rumble live stream and he's
back you know
what what is your take on that before we
dig into the we have a few i was just
gonna say i i of course i watched the
whole thing and um
that's classic tate right there uh it's
it's tate uh in his own environment you
gotta remember that the the li the video
he did which was his lat his last video
um
that was very controlled that was very
produced it was very uh um polished
let's just say i mean with with all the
kind of like the um the stock footage
and everything that goes and that the
piano music playing music yes the music
was a nice touch
and i it which really i kind of thought
was unnecessary but like i i get why
they did that but i think it was more of
a
well you've run me up you've crucified
me yeah i am the martyr now i'll accept
my punishment but before i go let me
explain to you what i'm really all about
and then when he does the rumble video
and i don't know for a fact
i'm not aware of any contract or any
kind of like you know co-op that the you
know co-branding that he has with rumble
although they are you know definitely
now co-branding
um and with getter i guess is the the
social media app that he's pushing right
now too um
i i'm not aware of any of that collab
like that but i will say this is there
was 140 145 000 live views of that hour
and 15 minutes he did on rumble which i
will say is more than tim poole and
ethan klein from h3 can generate
combined on their best shows so clearly
there's there's a want and a
popularity here where they want to see
what's the next thing that's coming from
from andrew
obviously the farewell video the last
video whatever is not the last video it
might be the last video he does on like
main you know mainstream media but you
know of youtube and twitch and tick tock
and all that but on alternative
platforms such as rumble such as odyssey
and by the way before anybody asks yes i
mirror to those sites as well
um but the the the fact that he's like
sort of back in in you know rare form
once again that's what people that's
what he knows that that's what his
audience wants the audience that he was
he was broadcasting to with the final
video versus the rumble video are two
different things or two different
animals the people who come to see him
on rumble they have to go seek him out
they have to hear through the grapevine
that he's going to be on rumble whereas
the vimeo video is there just for like
uh you know popular consumption of
anybody so that's but really that's
where he's coming back from
let's take a look at the the tonal
difference um i have this at 7 39. i
said it's a classic
it's really i mean honestly i laughed
out loud many times watching this it was
funny i'm not gonna lie even parts that
you're like did he just say that i left
but this is the tone that we're talking
about uh go to 739 you can start it
tyler
any woman who's around me feels safe i
thought we could sit around and talk but
no you decided my opinion isn't worth
anything you decided all the millions of
men who think like me are worth [ __ ]
nothing you decided that i didn't want
this war you [ __ ] did and then you
told me that i'm not allowed on your
platforms and you told me that i'm not
allowed anywhere well that's fine
because i have soldiers and we're going
to penetrate the matrix i'm going to
play a video and i want everyone to make
an instagram story and let's put it all
over [ __ ] instagram [ __ ] you
matrix this war has just begun i ain't
going nowhere you have my address you
know where i'm at come get me
this is the best
no you have to tyler do me a favor play
the video because i lost it you see him
he dances through the video i mean it's
like um there's music here i don't know
if you want to play that tyler it's up
to you but um okay so essentially we get
we don't play that because because
you'll end up getting a copyright strike
for the
anyways so bottom line thank you for
that rolo um but bottom line is he
learned the hard way he's got he comes
in
he's he's fired up it's a different tate
and no one knows now everyone's like
okay well what is he going to do next do
you have
any clear indication
of what he's going to do next how that's
going to manifest what it's going to
look like do you have a good guess
um and all honesty i think he's already
some people there's my biggest like
observation i think of this whole thing
is like you have to have seen this
coming so is this part of the i saw this
coming i knew i knew we were going to
have to sort of get into some we're
going to have to like pivot right we're
going to have to do some sort of new
branding we have to get to a new
platform uh i don't think that this took
them by surprise uh simply because even
you are saying do they have something
going on with rumble i think probably
everybody is thinking that too
um and he's definitely drawing an
audience uh you probably remember when
uh uh
donald trump got kicked off of twitter
and everybody wanted to go over to
parlor at that i was going to be the
twitter killer
or uh gab was going to be the twitter
killer none of that ever materialized
and even with donald trump saying hey
we're all going to go to parlor we're
all going to go to this this platform
he's always been saying hey we're going
to create a new platform for for our
people for our tribe or something like
that um that never materialized but
andrew tate can drag in more live views
than donald trump can on a on an
alternative platform so maybe there's
some hope in the fact that maybe they're
going to have a rumble could be an
alternative platform
in a real sense but again it's kind of
like joe rogan being on youtube and then
going over to spotify is he bigger on
youtube or is he bigger on spotify when
he goes over to spotify he's at the
mercy of the woke mob who is you know
wants to delete his old videos
and now he's just like don't care made a
hundred million dollars do whatever
you're gonna do i'm gonna keep doing
what i'm gonna do
is he more popular on spotify or was he
more popular on on uh on youtube is
andrew tate going to be as effective and
as uh notorious and as um you know
household name
now because he's been banned off those
those those formats
i know i hope i hope not i hope i hope
we can make it work i'm going to go over
to rumble i've already mirrored to
rumble anyways i've mirrored to odyssey
and rumble i've got you know i've got
getter i've got parlor i've got gab i'm
still waiting for people to talk to me
on like gab
but uh
is it is it going to be something that's
going to inspire people to come over to
a different platform i will i would hope
so but i i have to say i have to be
cautious in my optimism if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]
you